es ist sein erstes grosses politisches
vorhaben als kanzler eingeholt von
rasant steigenden infektionszahlen
getrieben von der union gebremst vom
eigenen koalitionspartner stadt
eckpunkte zu präsentieren wiederholt
scholz lediglich sein bekenntnis zur in
pflicht ich jedenfalls halte sich für
notwendig und werde mich aktiv dafür
einsetzen die regierung duckt sich weg
überlässt jetzt allein das feld den
parlamentariern doch parteiübergreifend
kommen immer mehr zweifel auf auch bei
der union die nach der verlorenen
bundestagswahl zur im flecht tendierte
jetzt allerdings viele offene fragen hat
wie oft muss man sich dann eigentlich
impfen lassen das ist ja das was gerade
sehr sehr viele beschäftigt eine
impfpflicht muss auch temporär sein und
von einer impfpflicht zu reden wo man
sich dann vier fünf oder sechsmal
pieksen lassen muss ist vielleicht etwas
was genau unter das kriterium
umsetzbarkeit oder das kriterium
umsetzbarkeit glaube ich nicht ganz
erfüllt die impfpflicht als
allheilmittel doch omikron zwingt zum
umdenken in bremen klettert die inzidenz
plötzlich sprunghaft in die höhe und das
obwohl sogar mehr als 85 prozent der
bevölkerung geimpft sind auf den
intensivstationen laut lka nur 14% cupid
patienten die trendwende wir sollten weg
kommen von den instanzen dass es jetzt
dringend geboten und sollten umstellen
auf den schutz des gesundheitssystems
und der menschen vor schweren
erkrankungen und tod das heißt nicht
mehr herdenimmunität oder gemeinschaft
schutz wie das jetzt zu optimistisch
heißt sondern wir werden uns darauf
einstellen müssen dieses virus wird
nicht mehr gehen wir müssen mit diesem
virus leben lernen
landauf landab proteste die einen gegen
die impfpflicht die anderen dafür die
freiheit des einzelnen gegen die
solidarität der gemeinschaft geimpfte
gegen ungeimpfte wissenschaftler warnen
vor einer zunehmenden polarisierung
das tut der gesellschaft nicht gut ja
zumal wir ja auch im prinzip die
vernunft zugeordnet haben ja also
vernünftig sind di die sich impfen
lassen unvernünftig sind die dies nicht
tun irrational sind die die sich weigern
rational sind die dies tun solidarisch
sind die die es tun das spaltet
natürlich ungemein oder hat schon die
gesellschaft ungemein gespalten ich
glaube wir haben auch sehr übersehen wie
menschenverachtend tatsächlich schon
über nicht geimpfte geredet wird ja sie
werden ausgegrenzt sie haben mich schon
jetzt ihre teilhabe am öffentlichen
leben zu weiten teilen verloren die
impfpflicht entzweit die gesellschaft
immer mehr fachleute wie hendrik strikt
mitglied der expertenkommission sind
dagegen die impfpflicht wird das corona
virus nicht ausrotten auch der chef der
ständigen impfkommission thomas mertens
meint das spaltet die gesellschaft da
wird zu viel druck aufgebaut die politik
im zugzwang im wahlkampf hatte sich die
fdp noch auf die seite der ungeimpften
gestellt und damit gepunktet
kann der ungeimpfte sich höchstens
selbst gefährden deshalb sollen auch im
herbst ungeimpfte zb in die gaststätte
gehen können vielleicht mit der
voraussetzung eines negativen tests
denen sie aber nicht bezahlen müssen das
macht die solidargemeinschaft sagen sie
jetzt sagen sie das auch noch nach den
wahlen das sage ich vor den war nach den
wahlen und 2010 sie gesehen dass die fdp
nach wien fahren sogar bereit ist nein
zu sagen zu einer regierung wenn sie
dazu sagen brechen im amt gibt sich
lindner nicht mehr als kämpfer für die
ungeimpften zeigt sich offen für die
impfpflicht wortbruch der vertrauen
kostet deshalb liegt die ampel regierung
auf bestehen der fdp keinen eigenen plan
vor stattdessen sucht sie den konsens
unter allen gesellschaftlichen gruppen
ihr sehen innerhalb der bevölkerung
derzeit noch eine breite zustimmung wir
sehen auch bürgerinnen und bürger die
bedenken haben die nachfragen haben das
merke ich auch bei mir vor ort im
wahlkreis und diese debatte werden wir
jetzt führen und sorgen und ängste auch
aufnehmen scholz hat sich festgelegt
ohne eigene mehrheit bei den liberalen
geht es um mehr als die impfpflicht es
geht auch um ihre glaubwürdigkeit